taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
today hey Tasties welcome to
t-a-s-d-e buds all right we got a nice
summertime battle for you today the
rocket pops AKA The Bomb Pop versus the
creamsicle Sal is defending the
disgusting revolting creamsicle and I am
defending the wonderful fruity vivacious
rocket pop audacious vivacious vivacious
vivacious you think you would describe
the rocket pop as vivacious I'm just
talking here I have a way with words and
I let them flow and they come out in the
way they come out and people find it
quite pleasing to be honest the rocket
pop
has its place in the annals of ice cream
truck and summertime history
we've all grown up with it right it's
never
been
a grand slam treat please it is finally
please summarize is nice I do love the
shape of it because the top of the
ridges actually make it more fun
the texture of it but at the end of the
day
it's the most basic of items it's a
it's a it's a it's a palatable I'm gonna
jump right into the battle we can jump
right into this because it sounds like
you want to jump right it's a palatable
enough Cherry you ready sure you ready
yeah and I can already
feel that this might be intense
I didn't change it it's okay don't worry
about it you'll never change I've
learned that about you I learned that a
lot about me yeah
ready yeah do we need a chance I'm just
ready to go all right all right let's do
a softie kick it up yeah let's kick it
up it's time to get salty it's something
that's I thought you're gonna do the ATC
Le buds first no no no no well I was
gonna do it the way we always do it all
right all right yeah yeah
ready yeah it's starting to get
something it's time to get salty it's
something it's salty you have the brain
of a goat I've never seen anything like
it I've never seen a man forget things
more you can't remember the order that
we do the chances you can forget that
goats are goats known to be dumb I don't
think they're smart
you know I oh is the goat smart
yeah yeah for an animal you're smart I
am the ghost I would say I'm the goat
yes I would say
at an animal are just as clever as dogs
and new research shows they form
relationships they problem solve and
they communicate with humans in much the
same way as this I got the brain yeah
and as and as I was always said about
you you have confidence the Goldfish
would have been better yours because I
forget yours Chow you're I'm telling you
that you're as smart as the smartest
Beast okay
actually is I battle every day I mean if
it was undiagnosed you'd have a hell of
a malpractice suit on your hands I
battle it every day
you battle it yes
come talk to the rest of us
I swear I'm ready I swear I don't see
the poll on here when did you send out
last night or
this is good this is great for momentum
oh it's it's it said your Tweet was sent
but it might have said it just this
happened last week yo yo Elon I hit send
on that [__] and shut my phone off I
gotta have it open and on to send a
Tweet now that's right there no it just
popped up I put that up an hour and a
half ago ready
yeah
do you remember what we're doing goat
brain yeah all right
oh oh no oh no
speaking of gold brain
I just spilled a drink but it's orange
and it's staining the carpet I mean you
spilled you spilled drink on yourself
the last show
Jesus Jesus gripe
okay good guy while he's down right well
all right ready yeah it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty it's time
to get salty
you know why you were sick
not because you have hay fever not
because you you know you just don't know
when to stop
[Laughter]
stick all the time because you put
yourself in a constant position to get
sick he traips around town you hang out
with unsavory types
doing all sorts of dive institutions and
your mouth is touching stuff all the
time that probably isn't cleaned
properly oh yeah sometimes you decide to
smoke no I don't smoke I haven't had a
cigarette in over a year year and a half
but you're always sick because you're
always out
and I think that subconsciously you're
looking for it
all right fair enough I think that you
could curb the amount of times you're
like I got something something I'm
running down I got a bug I said
something must have happened I got I got
I don't know you know I don't disagree
eliminate that but you refuse I don't
disagree with you to eliminate the
lifestyle that lends you know what I
eliminated yesterday when I felt sick
you know what I always do when I feel
sick I order McDonald's delivery I
didn't do it yesterday don't bring it up
I didn't do it yesterday I didn't do it
yesterday I didn't do it yesterday
because I said no I have to try this
I'll just buy the worst thing to nurse a
cold it's not good for you I know I do
it every time I'm sick though for
comfort food yeah you know what I did
yesterday they did a Red Baron pizza and
I called it a day
a frozen pizza yeah
why Red Baron it's what they had on the
gopuff app to deliver the puff yeah it's
a delivery app I never heard of it it's
like groceries in 10 minutes like one of
those things 10 minutes sometimes it's
like 15 minutes yeah 10 minutes 20
minutes like it's fast they have limited
selections go puff they don't sponsor us
but they're great they should anyway
watching we know that you are sponsor us
anyway yeah and then all right well okay
fine let's get into the rocket pop we
got to do okay
it's time to
b-a-t-t-l-e buzz all right I just
spelled battle wrong too holy God
there's an average Red Ice in there an
average lemon ice and then an average
blue eyes
well water ice flavor rice water ice has
levels like a rouse water ice or even a
Reedus water ice is or even a merino's
it's next level up but a rouse let's say
Ralph I I hold the standard too if you
don't know what that is Ralph is Staten
Island mainly but it's no now it's
Global oh it well so is Rita's is it
notable I believe so okay
but marinos is your average Supermarket
water that's that is a
it's a watered-down watery ice pop
that's not true I don't like about it
off the bat one the rapper always gets
stuck to it when you're opening because
of the freezer burn that that pop has
that's every popsicle ever of all time
ever this one particularly because it
has grooves
and when you go now sudden the bear
grips and now you're touching the ice
and it's melting and you're getting
sticky hands because you're trying to
peel the rest of the wrapper off right I
just want to put I just want to point a
fact out that just showed on the
Wikipedia scroll down a tiny bit pimp
just stop okay any child wanted to win a
Nintendo Game Boy I had to fill out
their personal information
bombpop.com did a thing did a promotion
with Nintendo and Game Boy in 2003 Walt
Disney Company made a deal with Wells
Dairy to release Buzz Lightyear Bomb
Pops this is the level that the rocket
pop and bomb pop are reaching they're
making deals with Disney and Nintendo
okay I think it's more aesthetic than
taste and weird you're wrong
it is so refreshing it is not a mediocre
watered-down version and you want to
talk mediocre you're oh my god dude the
creamsicle the worst flavor of a
popsicle that nobody cares about orange
this is
nobody cares about either of these
flavors this is the worst take you've
had in the history of taste buds no it's
okay yes it is no so why because the
creamsicle there are there are a few
things in our world
that combined to make something greater
than what they are alone things that if
they didn't exist like someone is
someone combined peanut butter and
chocolate
and blew everyone's balls off right
those two yeah creamsicle ain't no
peanut butter and chocolate you don't
think that you're nuts a delightful
orange sherbet nope combined with a
creamy vanilla ice cream even the
texture when you when you bite the
creamsicle the outer orange layer almost
acts as a shell it slightly has a little
bit of a crisp or um original to it
where it breaks almost like in pieces of
like
like ice and then the cream pieces fall
off the cream starts does not have that
consistency so it is so much fun to
to eat it really is fun to eat where I
think the bomb pop poses it's one of the
best problems the creamsicle is the
messiest of all pops bomb pop it's
messier than the creamsicle it's not the
bomb pop as the qualities of every
popsicle that existed however you you
unwrap the bomb the creamsicle it's
mission in Mission Impossible you might
as well hear the theme song what are you
talking about you're racing against the
clock before that thing melts what
you're doing with any popsicle whereas
with the creeps not a popsicle you have
two elements that are melting at
different uh ticks the the popsicle part
of the creamsicle and the ice cream are
melting at two different Paces correct
I'll tell you why the inside vanilla is
basically covered by the orange and that
core temperature of the vanilla is
staying cold and that reflects on the
outer orange let me tell you where your
problem is bud let me tell you where
your problem is Bud go ahead the bottom
the bottom is never covered by orange
there is a circle of exposed vanilla at
the bottom around the stem and that
starts and I love that you know what
that starts to drink because that's the
only access point for the drip and once
that begins which is probably 50 into
the pop I actually have a fun time going
reverse and licking the back side that's
right
[Applause]
will start dripping from all of its
surfaces oh and it's gonna now so will
the orange I hope you don't get any of
that dye on your white Bart Simpsons
wait a second are you gonna sit here and
say the creamsicle outer thing doesn't
drip also no from the outside it does
not yes it does it's a popsicle its
consistency does not drip and the inside
vanilla ice cream acts as a basically
frosting device to keep that outer shell
oh you're locked up this is such but I'm
talking about I'm serious this is oh my
God if I took okay you know what I wish
we had if I put a creamsicle and a
rocket pop on the table on a plate which
one do you think is going to melt first
I promise you it's the bom bom I promise
you I I don't know what that's based on
in any way based on what I just said
I I I disagree I think I think they melt
differently sure I'll agree with that
part I think the melting of the
creamsicle is far more problematic and
annoying because you're dealing with a
melting exterior of popsicle and a
melting interior of ice cream and your
creamsicle first of all that part that
is the magic let me focus on ice cream
and the orange combine the vanilla make
the creamsicle let me focus on the
bigger issue
two flavors you sat here and compared
this to peanut butter and chocolate two
flavors that do not go together couldn't
go together orange and vanilla they
couldn't go together more yeah because
every time I'm in the store I see orange
ice cream all the time it's not ice
cream it's sherbet it it popsicle part
is just orange popsicle flavor no it's
not yes it is no it is not no it is not
that is orange popsicle flavor oh that
was an interesting one pimp go back to
that one second did you know the
creamsicle was made in 1905 by 11 year
old Frank Epperson who experimented in
putting fruit juice ice cream fruit
juices not sherbet fruit juices popsicle
flavor babe this is 1905 with an 11 year
old okay this is not what we're talking
about right now okay it is orange
popsicle a round vanilla also known as a
dreamsicle why do they think they call
it a dreamsicle because you've got to be
gross you got it because it's a
nightmare to eat it uh you got it you
got it I'm telling you something
creamsicle is orange popsicle
orange popsicle it is not sherbet
iced orange juice orange juice coating
on it that's not ice cream it doesn't my
point is the flavors not orange ice
cream but my point is this you you see
you never see ice cream with orange bits
in it because it doesn't match this is
it this is the ice cream with the orange
in it this is it gross dude no you also
you can buy you can buy a a gallon of
ice cream that's half sherbet half
vanilla and you can buy it it's not
sherbet flavor it's what are we arguing
here Joe it's yours is made up of you
can get your watery Red Ice your watery
lemon ice and your watery blue eyes your
thing is singular alone and from 10
different companies there's only one
creamsicle pop it's its own invention
here's my point invention yours is just
water ice
your exterior is watery orange sickle it
is not sherbet flavored you think it's
sherbet flavor because you're mashing it
with the vanilla flavor I don't I don't
have any interest in getting into the
semantics of what you think the outer
shell consistency that's not semantic
I'm still talking about taste and
texture I am talking about what taste
made of it's delicious I am talking
about taste the flavor of tarte orange
does not mix well with vanilla flavor it
doesn't name bomb pop rocket pop baby
rocket pop rocket why do they call it
bomb pop it seems almost poetic that
amidst the threat of nuclear warfare
a bernothy and Merit I guess this is the
people came up with a Frozen treat to
cool down temperaments all over the
nation the boss was shaped like a bomb
oh six spins hence the name bomb Bob and
its color scheme reflected the Patriotic
Zeitgeist of the American
during the Cold War awesome National
Bomb Pop day so is there a creamsicle
day I sure there is I don't think so so
the bomb pop is is is literally is
literally fashioned after a weapon of
mass destruction It's Fashion after a
nuclear bomb yeah it's badass dude it's
badass with your pretty little
creamsicle see dude you can't eat a Bomb
Pop go eat it looking like Jenna Jameson
go eat it that's another powerful the
bomb pop it's phallic and everyone who
has to eat it everything you're saying
is awesome dude bombs Jenna Jameson
dicks it all sounds pretty great to me
dude now go eat a creamsicle with the
munchkins and Oz or wherever they eat
those things
cream
you have to blow a Bomb Pop you have to
blow it you gotta blow it this guy is
saying my pop is found when his injects
cream from the center of it into your
mouth my pop is well then they both have
have some traits then dude my pop is not
is is Americana it's yeah it's it's a
nuclear ride
it's American it's it's old school for
Americana creamsicle is has been around
since 1905 and everyone loves it
we already said all right sorry okay
dude you're gonna sit here you gotta at
the end of the day you gotta stack of
balls on you right now that you're gonna
try to argue that the flavors of vanilla
and orange are better than the flavors
of cherry all day lemon and whatever the
blue is I don't know what the blue is
keep chugging down that that dye that's
going to give you cancer oh yeah because
I'm sure you have pure you said yourself
your your exterior is not orange juice
it is not frozen juice you got dye
around the exterior that thing uh I I
honestly believe that there's no contest
that the on the creamy vanilla ice cream
and the orange outer shell
it's a I mean I mean I mean on anything
ever twice on Sunday better than the
combination of that watery down red red
lemon and blue ever since a young I see
ever since I was a young boy
dude when I was a young boy we'd go to
the mall and there was the orange julius
stand and my mom would always get me an
Orange Julius because I would say oh
that looks so fun I want to try I take
two sips and I go I hate this because it
was creamsicle flavor I ever since I was
a kid every time that happened yes it
happened three times because I was a
dumb kid and I thought I would I thought
it was missing something all right Goat
Boy uh I am telling you something cream
only Nazis pick creeps
I'm telling you ever since I was a young
kid
orange and vanilla ice cream did not
match his flavors to me I don't know how
else to say the first time I had sherbet
and by way of like a push pop too which
we've talked about in the last episode a
push pop might have gone up against
better than the creamsicle but it's the
same
Taste of orange and I was like what is
this like it's it it blew my mind oh and
I just realized red the red mines red
white and blue it's Old Glory
America's colors because it was a
warhead during the Cold War which
Communists didn't pick the pump up oh
here we go
we're gonna hit all the people with the
freaking
folks Joe DeRosa here to talk to you
about our sponsor game time you ever
tried to buy last minute tickets to an
event we all have and it's stressful
well game time is here to help you
relieve the stress alleviate the
eliminate the stress of buying those
tickets why because they're gonna get
you the best tickets available for the
best price available the best seats
available all of it in one place so you
can focus on what you want to focus on
the fun of the event I'm telling you it
happens to us all you want to go to
something you think something sounds fun
you know spontaneously let's go and then
it's a nightmare trying to figure out
how you're going to get there what are
the seats going to look like whatever
game time is here to help you deal with
all that they even have pictures of what
it looks like from your seat so you can
see what the view is from your seat and
they're offering 110 of the difference
if you are able to find tickets in that
same section or Row for less it's
amazing it's just it's just incredible
anyway download the game time app create
an account and use promo code taste buds
you're going to get 20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem the code taste buds
for twenty dollars off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed folks Joe DeRosa here
let me talk to you about rocket money
rocking money is helping you figure out
what those things are that you're
subscribing to that you often forget
about they're putting all your
subscriptions in one place so you can
manage them probably cancel a few of
them let's be honest because you forgot
you subscribed in the first place and
save some cash rocket money actually did
help me save money every month and they
help me figure out things that I had
subscribed to that I completely forgot
about it's a personal finance app it's
going to find and cancel all those
unwanted subscriptions it monitors your
spending and it helps you lower your
bills and it's all in one place so stop
throwing money away cancel The Unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
tastebuds that's rocketmoney.com
tastebuds
rocketmoney.com taste buds folks Joe
DeRosa here my new record
the penthouse papers collected readings
is dropping with a special thing records
on June 9th I had a two year long op-ed
column with Penthouse uh magazine and we
got all my columns together and I read
them into a microphone and from that
microphone to your ears how about that
folks it's a nice easy listen it's sort
of like an audio book I want you to
check it out I think you're going to
like it I'm really proud of the writing
I'm really proud of the pieces I was
proud of them when they ran in the
magazine I'm still proud of them and I
hope you enjoy them and that's why we
put this all together uh also if you're
in New York come to Joey Rose's open
seven days a week 11 30 a.m each morning
open into the night sandwiches available
all day long affordable drinks
affordable food always a good time Joey
Rose's
nyc.com for detail and you can get that
album where digitally on any platform
you stream your music from and if you
want to buy it you can actually pay to
download it from one of those sites like
iTunes that'll charge you but anyway no
physical release just a digital thing
to lull you to sleep each night
what's up guys first things first the
Impractical Jokers cruise is happening
January 22nd to the 26 2024 we are
hosting it with Eric Andre uh there's
gonna be a ton of comics and bands and
DJs it's our fifth one you can get
tickets right now it's 65 sold out uh at
pre-sale so get tickets right now at get
ship faced cruise.com you could also
enter to win a free trip and practical
jokers are finishing out the first leg
of our tour now through July all uh
dates and tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com in the coming
weeks we have Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City Nashville uh St Louis and am
I forgetting anything
that's it
with uh with the uh oh look this one's
for you rocket pops or generic flavored
ice while creamsicle is delicious and
creamy and original it
won the rocket pop is is
is just an amalgamation of some watered
down flavors of ice that aren't at its
best the rocket pop is like okay a great
creamsicle really hits the spot like a
rocket pop like I might not even have a
rocket pop if it was offered to me
thinking of a Bomb Pop makes me
creamsicle I was listening to you USA
I don't know thinking of a Bomb Pop
makes me creamsicle USA USA USA rocket
popular is that all that's good in this
country creepsicles taste like sherbet
and shame hence why DeRosa probably
picked it I love when they think I
picked the wrong thing it makes me happy
man I just don't I don't get it because
if we put vanilla ice cream against the
firecracker it would get destroyed the
rocket pop okay yeah yeah oh I don't I
don't know I don't think dude if you put
sherbet on sherbet against it or vanilla
ice cream against it I think both would
I love orange Sherbert and then why
wouldn't I love Arm Sherbert armed
Sherbert is not good sometimes I have a
quick flash of in front of my face of me
choking you all right sure but it's not
vanilla and orange flavor I just
pictured myself grabbing like this and
putting you against the wall orange
sherbet is not vanilla and orange
creamsicle in your mouth orange sherbet
is not vanilla and orange flavor but it
is the outer layer of the vanilla the
outer lay I didn't say can you please
look up what the new pop is not the 1905
11 year old boy pop
sickle I should call it also I think
creams homemade Creamsicle orange juice
not homemade mandarin orange orange
juice
store bought please store-bought
okay you're they're saying solid sherbet
exterior but is this what you're talking
about are you talking stop don't brush
past it that you were wrong hold on do
not brush I'm not brushing you do I'm
not perfect with the eggplant he Googled
eggplant pizza and honey and you brushed
past it I'm not brushing past it fine
it's got a new I'm not in a
can I say something yeah I have not had
a creamsicle since I was a young child
when they were only the single not like
that why did you shoot your mouth off if
you don't know nothing because I didn't
know they changed because they're so
iconic and they're so nice
here's the point stop trying to dig
yourself up with a goddamn I I am I will
admit that I'm wrong on the exterior but
you just spent 10 minutes of this
episode yelling at me about it I'm
telling you the creamsicle I was talking
about is the single you know what I'm
talking about right that was like a flat
wide thing I've never even seen that's
what I'm that's the thing I've never
seen that I've seen the single popsicle
style one oh okay you're talking about
the other phallic one yes okay
same thing
okay but that thing was like aren't that
one yeah that is orange popsicle with
our vanilla ice cream in the middle it
is not a sherbet exterior it's just not
I guess by company you want to split
hairs but you you know it's not
splitting ears it's called the
creamsicle the original Cream pop that's
the original so so
let's open that and see if it's Sherbert
like okay
I mean it just said what it was it said
it was Sherbert well no no the picture
of that thing that they
give me the contents pimp
well this probably well yeah this is not
going to say but I would really be
willing to bet Sal that because it's
made by a company called popsicle it's
probably orange popsicle without willing
to bet because you're just proven wrong
after 10 minutes of shouting like I
wasn't proven wrong there's a version of
it with orange Sherbert yes I am saying
you are you are correct okay here's
another thing that's now saying read it
out read it now read it out loud read it
out loud slow with good diction please
you have the floor okay so we're gonna
go off of ready for the website for
reference your
home-basedmom.com versus the brand
popsicle that makes the original orange
read what it says [__] cream see what
it says what is a creamsicle good here
crazy sickles we're always my summer
treat of choice when the neighborhood
Good Humor ice cream man came to visit a
creamy vanilla ice ice cream popsicle
coated in the layer of orange sherbet
okay it screams summer still doesn't
mean that I think Aaron sherbet and
vanilla ice cream go together let's take
it let's fine I'm 100 wrong Aaron
Sherbert and vanilla ice cream still
don't Mash mesh for me except they do
it's a it's a multi-million dollar
industry folks since 1905 I think it
tastes like [__] sorry I think it tastes
like [__] but you think that honestly I
like orange sure bro is it my favorite
sherbet no that's the best absolutely
pop it's just kind of water it down
there we go the best ice pop you're
saying it doesn't have its time and
place I'm not saying it doesn't hit a
spot but the rocket pop really if you
just really honest with yourself it's
not great it just ice water it's just
even the Cherry it's not like it's it is
it's not just ice water and it doesn't
taste like Sal lemon never tastes real
yes that lemon tastes chemically this is
yeah this is pathetic I know what the
taste is this is pathetically this is
pathetic I told you I don't know but
this is you don't see that as an issue
it's blue that's what it tastes like it
tastes good you don't see that as an
issue no I don't care when your taste
buds taste the blue what is your brain
my assumption is blue raspberry always
that's what I always think it is
blue raspberry
it's a flavor of something that you'll
find in your Blow Pops and Jolly
Ranchers and that sort of thing blue
raspberry and that that blue raspberry
goes with lemon listen to the words
listen to how much more awesome the
words are together blue raspberry orange
pop ugh
vanilla ice cream there's a reason
vanilla is an insult there's a reason
vanilla I'm trying to dress up blue
raspberry just by the way blue raspberry
blue raspberry blue raspberry blue
raspberry the name of a singer that runs
with Wu-Tang literally there's a singer
named blue raspberry that did features
on Wu-Tang Clan songs yes that is cooler
than vanilla ice cream 100 it's cool
than the word creamsicle yes I I
disagree
um creamsicles no I said it's cooler
than the word vanilla ice cream I said
it's cool no I said it's cooler than the
word vanilla ice cream you're talking
about you're taking one ingredient of
mine and I'm putting it against one
ingredient of yours you want to take
title of each rocket pup demolishes
cream I disagree creamsicle is a brand
new word invented just for that it
doesn't Exist Elsewhere so is rocket pop
rocket pop cream sickle those are words
that exist
so sickles one word cream and sickle are
two different words that exist
separately it's one word oh God this is
insane creamsicle did not exist please
time stamp this as the craziest argument
Sal has ever tried to make in the
history
this is so insane you're actually
arguing that the space between the words
is a detriment no I'm just saying that
creamsicle is a cooler word it's an
invented word so is creamsicle is one
word that was invented because they
decided to not put face rocket pop could
be
it's not one word
Sal it's the name of something
creepsicle is the name of some words
combined
creamsicle is two words combined if you
look up rocket pop in the dictionary
it's not there there is creamsicle but
it would be because it's one word oh my
God ciao oh my God I think it's cool
because I think they invented a name
they invented the name with rocket pop
too but they invented a word
rocket pop didn't invention by putting
two words together
sure that's how you do it okay yeah okay
sure yeah it's a word no we don't
existence
crazy [__] now you just want to go
against just grammar just English
language I want to go against grammar
you're going against grammar creamsicle
is a brand new invented singular word
it's a name so it means it's not a word
now it's not a word
it's not a word in the sense of
dictionary word it's a name they gave
something okay Joe is a name it's not in
the dictionary word that never existed
before
rocket pop dude rocket and pop are words
that were put together
ah
you're not you're not getting you you're
not getting what I'm saying no because
it's so crazy is anything in Rocky pop a
word that didn't exist before rocket pop
and nothing in Korea never say something
factual jokes creamsicle is a word that
cream sickle is two words they mush
together to make a name for a popsicle
you can't just say any word that's one
length one word in the English
dictionary was just two words it's not
in the English dictionary creamsicle is
not a real word it's a [__] name for
a popsicle they made up it's not in the
dictionary but that's not what I'm
saying [__] oh my God I'm just
saying that it is a brand new word that
was invented okay here's the here's what
you're saying ready here's what you're
saying this person's name is Mary Jo
spelled
m-a-r-y-j-o this person's name is Mary
Jo spelled m-a-r-y space j-o-e that name
is more valid and inventive because
there's not a space between the two
words that's exactly what you're saying
you said exists ready everything you say
sickle and cream are two different words
it's one word it reforms a new word
I think that you are ridiculous to even
just push back on okay it's just plain
let's move on this is this is I think
it's neat that those things become one
word literally the most angry I've ever
been ever at an argument you've made I'm
I'm suppressing my anger as well
sickle a suffix combined Okay so my sick
will be spelled different
so you might have avoid
[Laughter]
I
oh man hold on hold on hold on anybody
got a Xanax
I need to I need this I need to my mic
didn't come out did it I need to hold on
a second here
because I'm I got lightheaded
I got lightheaded
there's no one on this goddamn planet
want to murder someone or have a heart
attack at the exact same time I thought
my mom you know the pride I think my mom
was tough to deal with do you know the
pride I take in there you
all like
you all like my mom's like the
grasshopper to your whatever the [__]
you are
you I'm the master and rage me and I
have to imagine
our listeners and if you were on his
side with all that Jibber Jab a second
ago and then he just proved himself
wrong and it has a little chuckle about
it like it wasn't aggravating and he
didn't take up our time for another 10
minutes then you're wrong that's two
times in this episode for 20 minutes
Hume
that you argued and shouted at my face
and then went okay so I'm wrong
I hate you you feel so good
creamsicles the new
new actually I would say rocket pop is
that rocket pop is better in that sense
for that joke no it's not big signals
that's it's that person's joke it's
funny it made it but I was like a
professional comedian and Rocket pop
would land oh god well okay sorry sorry
the fan who's not a professional
comedian that made us both laugh didn't
nail the bit in the way you would
because it's against your thing don't
come at me with garbage people who
laughed at it you [__] you laughed at
it the concept shut up because it
doesn't resonate that's not true Rick
that's not true give me a break Joe Joe
so rocket pops are for people who think
there are only two genders
laughs
can can you hey Dick hey Dick yeah talk
about how you were you just just
admitted that you were completely wrong
after shouting at me yeah I said it
already I was wrong why would you do
that why would you because I thought it
was right but but why do you think that
you could have the Gusto and the gall to
shout at someone when your argument is
unchecked because I thought I was right
because sickle is a word but you and I
thought it was I didn't know it was
spelled different are you nuts bro yeah
did you ever see the Lord popsicle
anywhere
who am I to know who are you to know is
what you're saying now yet that's what
you based your shouting at me on for 20
minutes of this episode okay as long as
we're clear yeah as long as we're clear
yeah well I thought it was right
you gotta understand something I thought
I was right which made me write in that
time but you don't and then check if
you're right and that's what will
eventually lead to me having a stroke I
had the strength to say I am wrong now
you're patting yourself on the back
you're wasting all the time I have the
character now I have the character to
say all right the character you say I
was wrong okay your [__] is being
re-categorized as strength character
character character yeah
tell from your face that you don't
believe a word he's saying
you'll never know will you no we know we
know zoom in on that we know no I'm
saying you'll never know your smirk
indicates to me that you know you're
full of horseshit
Mountain Dew's newest flavor is Bomb Pop
inspired summer freeze so which show is
the Newport of ice cream so is it so is
Twisted Tea has a rocket pop flavor is
it the Mountain Dew Bomb Pop flavor uh I
would like to read more of the phones
because these these all seem very funny
very happy uh 33. okay cool creamsicle
Rock creamsicle rocket bar is okay
though too
the prime flavor is good but you can't
beat a creamsicle never heard of a
rocket pop come on dude read the read
the whole thing the mix of two are
different layers of the two different
layers are the goat I don't agree goat
is uh
how has this guy never heard of a rock
about sucking on a rock but pop is more
American than standing for the national
anthem sucking on a rocket pop is oh wow
that's a good one nc7 cream spelled like
Wu-Tang style that's good that's word I
wouldn't get either from the ice cream
truck
but orange creamsicles are such a unique
treat I got to go for that over the also
delicious come on let me get come on
this might be close today because we're
seeing some uh [__] I like both but
whoever chooses to mix Dairy ice cream
with orange sherbet are the people that
like orange flavored chocolate thank you
and brush their teeth after drinking
orange juice
oh wow
ice cream truck in my hood we give away
items that were close to expiration for
free even the homeless people didn't
want the creams that goes Joe can pop my
rocket oh wow thank you very much
Larissa wait how does she know that
you're rocket pop
she's just I don't think she does she's
just saying you know or maybe she does
just through osmosis rocket pops are
Heaven Sent sticks and if you choose a
thick ass heavy ass creamsicle over a
light and succulent bomb up you're wrong
that's a terrible take why is it
terrible because it's true they're
they're not heavens and sticks and what
does she mean that's her opinion heavy
creamsicle yeah creamsicles heavier
that's cream in it it's heavier are you
talking about fractions of ounces right
now oh please fractions of algae heavy
as it's cream is a heavier thing to eat
than a popsicle yes you want to talk
facts now come on dude oh you know
you're the same as me you you throw [__]
out the window when you want to hear it
do you act like you're better than me
you're no better than me you're sick I
don't act like that show you know why
you don't like me because I'm a mirror
you lunatic you know what you're a
lunatic you know you're losing you try
to victimize yourself you turn around to
me and tell me that I don't like you and
I give you I try to victimize myself you
said you're gonna have a stroke because
of me but you're turning around now and
saying that I'm being a jerk to you when
you have had terrible etiquette and
behavior during this podcast so far so
now you're turning it on don't you how
what did I do this episode or the whole
podcast I thought you meant the whole
show entirely oh today just today you
can't turn this on me and say that I I I
I I'm but you just
her opinion you can't have an opinion
know that cream is not a heavier thing
than Frozen liquid why can't I have
anything not good
because that's shall that's like saying
it's my opinion that steak is not as
heavy a food as spinach it it's a
heavier food I think that that just it
is that's not creamsicles to creamsicles
if I'm being honest okay the thin layer
of vanilla ice cream in the middle of a
small you have said repeated it's not
gonna be like this is
here to talk to you about manscaped
manscaped a wonderful sponsor here at
the taste buds podcast it is almost the
Fourth of July it's basically here and
what is more American what is more
Fourth of July than a bald eagle you
want to talk bald you got to do some
trimming sometimes especially when
you're going to be spending some time
outside swimming around that sort of
thing you know what kind of German I'm
talking about I don't need to get too
graphic here but manscaped is helping
you do it cleanly efficiently and
without any danger we've all had a
problem or two a Nick or two if you will
when we're dealing with that area
manscape is here to help you prevent
that with the performance package 4.0
inside that package you're getting the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer you're getting the
weed whacker for your ear and nose hair
trimming you're getting the crop
preserve or ball deodorant keeping you
fresh you got crop reviver tone toner
you've got performance boxer briefs
comfy and you got a little travel bag to
hold all those goodies I like what
they're doing here
again it's it's they're making a product
that helps you trim in the downstairs
area and the upstairs area that's where
the beard hedger trimmer comes in
cleanly efficiently safely without all
the bumps and nicks and cuts anyway take
your freedom balance to the next level
go to manscapes.com get 20 off with free
shipping when you use the discount code
taste buds 2-0 again
manscaped.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the discount code taste
buds 2-0 get your Independence back this
Independence Day and unlock the
confidence within you with manscaped
your your about me your pop sucks it's
frozen water and then you're gonna in
the in the next breath say frozen cream
is not heavier than that okay stop if
you're talking literal literal sure but
if that's what we're talking hold on
she's talking about how it makes her
feel she's talking about when I eat it
and that makes her feel that way sure
and for me when I eat a creamsicle I'm
not like oh God okay it's so heavy it's
for you I can't for you about me you
didn't say that you dismissed what she
said as being a terrible argument you
are yeah you're terrible so you said
that's a terrible argument when you when
you don't have something to latch on to
don't you start to latch on to things
that are the most absurd things no no no
you said that that was a terrible
argument it's not you just admitted it
you look at what the uh let's just say
what the weight is of a popsicle versus
the cream uh okay they're probably both
like three ounces or whatever you know
heavier food doesn't necessarily mean
the literal way sure but I mean how
heavy is that little sliver of cream in
between the arms wow the little little I
love that this that this the defining
quality of this treat the amazing
amazing Center of this tree has now been
reduced to a tiny oh a wafey a barely
noticeable sliver of cream now that it's
convenient the width of the width of a
creamsicle is what a quarter inch oh
total you are people let me you wanted
to let you say something when you won't
even let me address your thing that you
just said you won't listen you don't
want to shut up to let me prove you
wrong a creamsicle width in total is
about a quarter inch the inside of that
for the vanilla ice cream by by
inherently by nature of that design is a
thin layer of cream creamsicle is not a
quarter inch first of all with with
that's about an inch Sal I'm saying
width maybe maybe a half inch my point
Joe is that the [__] vanilla ice
cream in the middle does not amount to
something heavy that the stomach can't
handle so it it's not a matter of the
stomach can't handle it's a matter of
cream for some people I'm not comparing
cream to ice Joe I'm just comparing you
are no but I'm not I'm not I'm comparing
it in these forms okay if I ate if I eat
a frozen cube of popsicle liquid from an
ice cream tray or a frozen cube of cream
the Frozen cube of cream is a heavier
food literally yes but you will not she
says I don't like it because it's too
heavy if you ate one cube of ice cream
you wouldn't be like oh maybe it's too
heavy for her it doesn't mean
oh it's talking about me bro you said
her argument's a terrible argument my
opinion is that there you go oh you
don't know ding ding ding dude
I'm so happy you just said that and the
psychology 101 every therapist on planet
Earth that would tell you that the
owning of your own statement to say I in
my opinion that is wrong or I don't
agree with that is the qualifier of what
makes it your opinion that you just the
more you talk I mean I think people are
changing the channel I honestly you ever
see an airplane where the woman won't
stop talking next to him and he hangs
himself and lights himself on fire
no you're like you know what you're like
you're like the you're like the guy that
goes you're like the dumb guy that goes
classical music sucks
doesn't have the ability to go in my
opinion I don't care for classical music
those are two different sentences that's
funny what she said is a fair argument
to you it doesn't bother you to her it
does that's the idea of the pot on why I
talk doesn't mean it's a bad argument
it's a fair argument I just disagreed
with her you said it's a bad argument
you didn't say I disagree I said it's a
bad argument love to take each other to
court over something and represent
ourselves and I would love a jury and a
judge to listen to us argue because
there's no greatest satisfaction than if
I got legal official legal people and
beat you in an action the arrogance that
you think you would I would I love the
Arabic Roy you you are crazy one trial
you are crazy
let me tell you why because they don't
let me tell you why you wouldn't have
[__]
[__] buddy let me tell you why you
wouldn't have a chance though because
you're not allowed to talk over other
people in court how about that okay let
me talk to you this episode Joe we're
both guilty of it you [__] dirty
prick what are you talking you know what
you're two douchebags you're a pack of
two douchebags that you buy yeah the
fans of the fans have seen the fans have
seen okay you never yelled over me and
you I love it in the history of this
podcast you can't say something oh now
we're talking guilty of the history of
the podcast okay all right listen I'm
just telling you scream to the fact that
you get I'm just you can't deal with the
fact that I said to you she didn't make
a bad argument she just made an argument
you disagree with a bad argument would
be a bad argument repeat that already a
bad argument would be creamsicles are
bad because they go rotten too
frequently that's a bad argument it's
not a good argument if there's no proof
of that there's nothing to it what she
said is a fact for some people way past
that dude that's our opinion this is my
opinion I don't think she's so sad I
shouldn't have said it that way
absolutely not I fully agree what I said
to begin with you said that's a bad
argument creamsicle is not enough to
make me feel like this is heavy this
one's not you you yeah right so it's so
just take okay so she has a creamsicle
and she has a rocket pop one of them's
like oh God the creamsicles just too
much WoW again I think for you most
people wouldn't say that both two three
once again you have said repeatedly
maybe some people maybe maybe some
people it bothers them it doesn't bother
me all I'm taking issue with is you
saying that's a bad argument that's not
a bad argument then if you can recognize
that that's an argument valid for some
people a bad argument is a bad argument
did I say the words that's a bad
argument yes that's what I keep saying I
say the words that she said that that's
a bad argument uh you you dismissed it I
don't remember did I say this is you
said that he's screaming about again
that will prove wrong in a couple of
seconds again yeah he wants to go he
wants to go over three in this one you
went like this that's a bad argument in
my opinion for the reasons I'm saying
Joe it is another with the semantics
you're latching on to something because
the wheels are falling off your other
arguments that's not semantics and I got
news for you buddy law in a court of law
all you got is semantics all right you
want to talk about not getting semantics
we should look into please if we could
take each other to court and represent
ourselves let's go to small claims court
let's think of something that's true
that we have a different opinion on that
we disagree with and let's go to small
games Court I don't care if it's [__]
a hundred dollars and we represent each
other I
I need to do it and I need to do it fast
I need to do it this week I want to beat
you in court this kind of bloodlust you
just got a bloodline
to be televised and I want everyone to I
want to kill you inspiring I can't wait
until you start yelling and have such
memories and the judge like slams the
gavel and tells you
okay I can't wait and I can't wait till
the judge goes your gaslighting Sal stop
it yeah okay okay all right how about we
uh let the fans decide in the comments
and bring it up next week please
please let's let the fans decide you
heard it the argument about the creation
I'll say mine we'll just say clean say
it for 30 seconds clean just so they
understand don't interrupt me then go
ahead
my problem was the person who said that
creamsicle is a heavier treat
my problem is not whether or not that
bothers salary is the my problem is that
Sal said that's a bad argument and
dismissed it as if it couldn't possibly
be true that cream is a heavier food
than frozen water as he has put it and
just because he doesn't think that in a
moment where it was convenient for him
despite saying repeatedly factually sure
cream is heavier that he dismissed that
as a bad argument therein it is not a
bad argument it is just something that
doesn't bother him but bothers other
people so I can't have the opinion that
that's not a strong argument
UK a bad argument because when you say
my opinion is I mean I think it's a week
a week or a bad argument because if
we're dealing in actual size like if she
was gonna eat like you know a a you know
a cup like a cup of Frozen ice or a cup
of ice cream yes when you get
exponentially larger the cream is
heavier but in the two things we're
comparing there is not enough vanilla
cream in there to substantiate a
difference technically and that's why I
think it's not a strong good argument
because I think that I can say my my
point makes sense at that level at two
ounces for the whole bar the vanilla
cream doesn't really play a factor the
thickness of it against the rocket pop
in this scenario which is the only
specific two things we're talking about
sure on a bigger level or in general if
you get if you have a lot more ice cream
and a lot more ice the cream is heavier
but I don't think it comes into play
here because I think it's too minute and
that was my point and that's a fine
point to say that she's got a weak
argument there that is totally normal I
disagree I think you dismissed her
argument because it doesn't apply to you
and I think somebody who I just
explained I know I understand so what
now you're telling me that I didn't say
what I what I just said why I said it
you just said it because I disagree you
I think you you just hold on you just
said it now don't tell me I didn't say
what I've been saying the whole time
just hold on a second hold on a second I
gotta get I gotta take I gotta I gotta
take it calm down all right relax it's
hard it's hard calm down hard you guys
by the way somebody who's lactose
intolerant doesn't matter how much cream
it is okay cream is triggering
or her
and by the way you have a disrespect for
the lactose intolerant because I have an
ice cream issue first lactose to
tolerant you [__] [__] I've had an
ice cream issue for years that you
refuse to recognize every time I see you
you say you want some ice cream and I
say I can't eat ice cream and you go
what are you talking about next week get
me a blow up doll throw a pair of
glasses on it and put it there because
it's the same [__] okay I'd rather
talk to a blow up doll that's me that
that blow-up doll will have better
points that's me this man right here
that's me I don't know how you
are alive because you're because you
walk around and you have to make
decisions all day and the amount of
compounded bed takes you have you should
be in a ditch somewhere at this point
because you don't you are not like
another human being yeah contrarian yeah
for just the sake of it no you hate
everything you argue about everything
you have a generally unpleasant
disposition that you bring with you
everywhere and to to know that you made
it to 45 or 46 is really outstanding I
actually commend you for it okay okay
am I laughing back at you I'll lie right
back at you
sorry I don't walk around bubbly because
I don't have a famous TV show where
everybody around me wipes my ass every
five minutes for me oh sorry I'm out
there in the real world and you're
walking around with a group of people
going Sal is everything okay
warm enough
did we get the pretzels that you like so
are they too salty Sal I'm sorry I'm out
there dishing it up with the real people
dealing with the real problems on the
train I show his face about me talking
to real people but God I'll let you
finish because I can I can counter this
and demolish you in a second so go ahead
go ahead counter okay this narrative
that you always try to push sometimes
when we get heated over the course of
these two years is something that you
literally made up right I don't act like
that I don't have people around me like
that nothing like that happens you're
just taking a pot shot because it's kind
of low-hanging fruit and you think you
can apply it because people don't know
me well but I don't have a team of
people around me I'm the most average
person in the world I don't think I'm
better than anyone I don't act like that
but you said I have a team of people
around me kissing my ass ads is this too
salty is this that I have a famous TV
show I'm not with the regular people
talk [__] would you not say would you
not say you wouldn't know if you didn't
know me I don't act like that I don't I
didn't say I'm gonna flash you like that
I never trade people I never said you
have no basis no one's ever thought that
you just it's so easy for you to go
you're famous and so you are
disconnected and it's not funny it's not
equally easy for you to go you're Grump
and you're the disposition
the thing you said is that you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right boatloads of money and fame
don't add to a joyous disposition you're
right you're right that's the argument
no you just changed it it I didn't
change it my point is is we could take
cheap shots at each other all day about
why we activate probably because of Fame
babe it's in my DNA oh please it's in
your DNA it's up your ass
[Laughter]
please you've got a dark side to you now
you're yelling at me you got a dark side
of you and I got a bubbliness to me and
we don't let this we don't let the world
often see that other side of us but it's
there
and you know it's there oh you're
oh yes now now the thing you have
against me is that I'm bubbly no you I'm
saying you're saying I'm a group you
know I have a tender wonderful side of
course I didn't say you didn't do that I
didn't know but he's more sentimental
than me
please I'm probably maybe you look
competitive sure yes but please you know
how sentimentary I didn't say that you
didn't have that you said yeah you said
you have a shitty whatever the term was
disagree
I think to say I carry it everywhere you
made it so
much
wow all right well you know
what I'm saying we're both low-hanging
fruit things that we're going after here
so Joe
real oh you're rich and you
you oh stop it at times you wouldn't
agree Joe you wouldn't agree for real
and at times at times do you not
enjoy the perks of of a Pampered
lifestyle and would he never sure oh
please come on never never ever but what
is the Pampered lifestyle are you
talking of I'm just saying you're
calling me a grump you're saying what
I'm saying to you is low hanging fruit
I'm saying you're saying low hanging
fruit and I'm I'm taking a shot if I
have extra extra income to spend
sometimes frivolously or I'm saying Mr
bubbly over here uh yeah because dude
I've been I've been I've been poor in my
life
I've had no health coverage I grew up
lower middle class I worked for 20 years
I understand you were break you want to
use it against me you're using
I'm just I don't understand
me this drives me crazy about you this
drives me crazy about you it's a weird
double standard you have you'll take
like a really personal shot jovially but
it's personal and then I don't don't do
that thing where you're getting personal
I didn't get I'm not getting it but your
retort to it is these like fundamental
truths about why what I'm saying is now
having a problem with the way that I'm
defending the argument I'm just saying
you may know that you do a lot with like
oh I'm in my cast
so far off you took a broad swing at me
it was funny you thought known to be
grumpy I called you grumpy you are known
to be famous and Wealthy I called you
famous and Wealthy you didn't you talked
no you didn't you said my attitude is
such that people serve me and I'm in my
castle and I don't know it was a joke
you made it I know it's the point of the
podcast so let it so just leave it at
the joke is my point you took a broad
stroke at me I took one back you stopped
talking about any time you want this is
you did literally the nature of what
we're supposed to be doing and now
you're saying that the things are
getting too personal at all not at all
okay fine I'm not offended then awkward
trying to make jokes here okay then I'll
retort to what you said to me in the way
that you retorted to what you said to me
here's fundamentally why it's not true
that I'm a grump I deal with the real
world every day and people are shitty
and I get annoyed at things and I show
it it's a great defense okay great I
want to defend it I just want to insult
you so I'm I gotta be honest today I'm
in the tizzy because I can't find follow
you today the logic leaps that you I
love that you think it's just me it's
amazing it's amazing I don't know bro I
don't know read the comments sometimes I
don't know peruse the comment sometime
uh you'll see that there's two people at
work here
okay
all right all right in here we read the
phones let's just go to Humble Pie
that's why I think you're gonna win I
don't know the rocket pop is just more
it has just more of a it's more famous
4 600 votes here we go I know I'm gonna
it's close
it was close it is a comeback Trail
blazing The Comeback Trail rocket pop by
53.2 percent
creamsicle loses at 46.8 it is close but
I still love you buddy I love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they look two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food